– Also, es gibt heute Abend
mehrere Veranstaltungen.
Im Heimathaus gibt’s Volksmusik …
– Auf keinen Fall!
– Dann hier … Rockmusik im Club.
– Das hört sich schon besser an.
– Ja, aber die Sängerin ist
ziemlich populär.
Ich denke, die Tickets sind ausverkauft.
– Gibt es keine Tickets an der Abendkasse?
– Ich glaube nicht …
– Schade. Was gibt’s denn sonst noch?
– Es gibt noch ein Musical oder wir
können ins Theater gehen.
An der Theaterkasse gibt es
bestimmt noch Tickets.
– Klingt gut.
– Hast du Lust, meinen Neffen
Nico kennenzulernen?
– Ja. Warum nicht?
– Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry …
– Lisa!
– Liebe Gäste, liebe Gäste,
und jetzt ein kleines Konzert
von unseren guten Freunden:
Lisa, Sebastian und Nico!
Viel Spaß!